SENATE COMMITTEE ON HEALTH WILL
COME TO ORDER. THANK YOU FOR,
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN, FOR
ATTENDING THIS AFTERNOON. AS
USUAL, WE'RE GOING TO ALLOW SIX
MINUTES OF TESTIMONY PER SIDE.
WE HAVE 12 BILLS ON THE AGENDA.
NINE OF THEM ARE ON OUR PROPOSED
CONSENT CALENDAR. I WILL READ
THOSE NOW AND PROBABLY READ THEM
AGAIN WHEN WE ESTABLISH A QUORUM
AND TAKE UP THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. ITEM NUMBER TWO, AB
1943. ASSEMBLYMEMBER WEBER,
MEDI-CAL TELEHEALTH WITH
AMENDMENTS. ITEM NUMBER FOUR,
ASSEMBLY BILL 1792. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RODRIGUEZ, EMERGENCY
MEDICAL SERVICES PERSONAL
PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT, ITEM
NUMBER FIVE. ASSEMBLY BILL 2146
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RODRIGUEZ.
PRODUCT SAFETY WEARABLE PERSONAL
FLOTATION DEVICES, ITEM NUMBER
SIX AB 1936 ASSEMBLY MEMBER,
CERVANTES MATERNAL MENTAL HEALTH
SCREENINGS. ITEM NUMBER SEVEN AB
2129 ASSEMBLY MEMBER,
PETRIE-NORRIS. IMMEDIATE
POSTPARTUM CONTRACEPTION. ITEM
NUMBER EIGHT ASSEMBLY BILL 2131
ASSEMBLY MEMBER, VALENCIA.
CERTIFIED NURSE ASSISTANT.
TRAINING PROGRAMS WITH
AMENDMENTS. ITEM NUMBER NINE.
ASSEMBLY BILL 2154. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BERMAN MENTAL HEALTH
INVOLUNTARY TREATMENT, ITEM
NUMBER TEN AB 2556. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER, JACKSON BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH AND WELLNESS SCREENINGS
NOTICE WITH AMENDMENTS AND ITEM
NUMBER 11, AB 2841. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WALDRON CONTROLLED
SUBSTANCES REACHER'S RESEARCH
ADVISORY PANEL MEETINGS. IT'S AN
URGENCY MATTER WITH AMENDMENTS
WITH THAT, WE'LL START AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE WITH OUR FIRST
ITEM, ITEM NUMBER ONE, ASSEMBLY
BILL 82. ASSEMBLY MEMBER WEBER.
DIETARY SUPPLEMENTS FOR WEIGHT
LOSS AND OVER THE COUNTER. DIET
PILLS. PROCEED WHEN READY.
WELL, THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR. I AM
HERE TO PRESENT AB 82. AB 82
WOULD BAN THE SALE OF DIET PILLS
TO MINORS UNLESS PRESCRIBED BY A
DOCTOR. THIS BILL WOULD
ESTABLISH AN ID CHECK FOR THE
SALE OF DIETARY SUPPLEMENTS AND
DRUGS TO PREVENT MINORS FROM
EATING DISORDERS. EATING
DISORDERS ARE A VERY SERIOUS
PUBLIC HEALTH PROBLEM AFFECTING
PEOPLE OF ALL RACES, AGES, AND
GENDERS, BUT IT'S ESPECIALLY
TROUBLING FOR OUR YOUNG PEOPLE.
WHILE CALIFORNIA IS AT THE
FOREFRONT OF REGULATIONS
CONCERNING WEIGHT LOSS, DIETARY
SUPPLEMENTS AND DIET PILLS, WE
DO NOT PROHIBIT THE SALE OF
THESE PRODUCTS TO MINORS.
DESPITE WELL DOCUMENTED DANGERS,
TEENS ARE ESPECIALLY TARGETED BY
THESE DIET PILLS AS SELF-IMAGE
ISSUES ARE PREVALENT IN OUR
ADOLESCENTS. THE OPPOSITION
QUESTIONS THE CLAIMS THAT
DIETARY SUPPLEMENTS ARE LACED
WITH DANGEROUS SUBSTANCES WHEN
JUST LAST FALL, THE FDA FOUND
WEIGHT LOSS PRODUCTS CONTAINED
YELLOW OLEANDER, WHICH IS
POISONOUS AND CAN ALSO CAUSE
HEART PROBLEMS. THIS BILL IS
NEEDED SO THAT PARENTS MAY BE
AWARE OF THE PRODUCTS THEIR
CHILDREN ARE TAKING, AND TO
PREVENT TEENS FROM LOOKING TO IT
TOWARDS A QUICK WAY TO LOSE
WEIGHT. THE LEGISLATURE HAS
PASSED A VERY SIMILAR BILL
RECENTLY. IN 2022. THE GOVERNOR
VETOED THIS BILL AND HIS VETO
MESSAGE. HE DIRECTED THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH TO
CONVENE A WORKGROUP TO STUDY AND
DEVELOP A PUBLIC POLICY TO
ADDRESS THE CONCERN OF DIETARY
SUPPLEMENTS AND MINORS. THE
WORKGROUP PUBLISHED THEIR
RECOMMENDATIONS IN FEBRUARY OF
THIS YEAR, AND AMONG THE
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT ARE IN THIS
BILL INCLUDE AGE RESTRICTIONS
FOR BOTH DIETARY SUPPLEMENTS AND
OVER THE COUNTER DRUGS, AND
GRANTING THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
AUTHORITY TO ASSIST WITH
ENFORCEMENT. ADDITIONALLY, THIS
BILL REQUIRES THE CDPH TO
DEVELOP A NOTICE TO WARN
CUSTOMERS OF THE POTENTIAL
DANGERS WHEN USING THIS PRODUCT.
WITH THAT SAID, YOUR VOTE TODAY
WILL ENSURE THAT WE CONTINUE
WORKING TO PREVENT ALREADY
VULNERABLE YOUTH FROM
UNNECESSARY HEALTH PROBLEMS AND
EATING DISORDERS ASSOCIATED WITH
WEIGHT LOSS SUPPLEMENTS AND OVER
THE COUNTER PILLS. TODAY,
TESTIFYING AND WITNESS, WE HAVE
NÓI LUZ RIVAS SUBIA, A HIGH
SCHOOL STUDENT FROM THE
SACRAMENTO AREA. ALI EVANS, A
COMMUNITY ADVOCATE AND DOCTOR.
SONIA FRAUSTO WITH TEN ACRES
PHARMACY. THANK YOU. OKAY.
WELCOME THANK YOU FOR JOINING
US, LET'S START WITH, MY LEFT,
YOUR RIGHT. INTRODUCE YOURSELF
AND PROCEED WHEN READY. GOOD
AFTERNOON. HONORABLE MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS NATIVE
SABAYA. I'M A HIGH SCHOOL JUNIOR
FROM MARYLAND HIGH SCHOOL IN
SACRAMENTO, AS WELL AS A YOUTH
ADVOCATE FOR THE STRATEGIC
TRAINING INITIATIVE FOR THE
PREVENTION OF EATING DISORDERS,
BASED AT THE HARVARD SCHOOL OF
PUBLIC HEALTH. I WOULD LIKE TO
SHARE MY EXPERIENCES WITH
WITNESSING FIRSTHAND THE
CONSEQUENCES OF DIET PILLS ON
THE MENTAL HEALTH OF MY CLOSE
FRIENDS AND MY PEERS, AS WELL AS
EXPRESS MY STRONG SUPPORT FOR AB
82, WHICH WOULD BAN THE SALE OF
DECEPTIVE OVER-THE-COUNTER DIET
PILLS AND WEIGHT LOSS
SUPPLEMENTS TO MINORS IN OUR
SOCIETY. THE PRESSURE TO CONFORM
TO BODY IMAGE IDEALS IS
OVERWHELMING, ESPECIALLY FOR
TEENAGERS THROUGHOUT MIDDLE
SCHOOL AND EARLY HIGH SCHOOL, I
TOO STRUGGLED WITH ACCEPTING MY
BODY AS A RESULT OF MY WEIGHT. I
GRAPPLED WITH MY OWN MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUES AND TRIED HARD TO
CHANGE WHO I WAS IN PURSUIT OF
ACCEPTANCE BY MY PEERS. BUT MANY
OF MY PEERS ALSO FACE
SELF-ESTEEM ISSUES, ESPECIALLY
DURING THE COVID 19 PANDEMIC,
WHICH ONLY EXACERBATED THESE
PROBLEMS AS IN RECENT YEARS, THE
RISE OF TOXIC GYM CULTURE AND
SOCIAL MEDIA HAVE INCREASED IN
PREVALENCE, ONLY FEEDING INTO
THESE HARMFUL BEAUTY IDEALS.
CHILDREN ARE CONVINCED THAT THEY
NEED TO ACHIEVE AN UNATTAINABLE
BODY, AND THEY OFTEN TURN TO THE
DECEPTIVE CLAIMS TOUTED BY
WEIGHT LOSS SUPPLEMENT COMPANIES
PAIRED WITH THE PROMOTION OF
STRICT DIET PLANS. CHILDREN
ULTIMATELY DEVELOP POOR MENTAL
HEALTH AND BODY IMAGE ISSUES. IT
IS HEARTBREAKING TO SEE SOME OF
MY CLOSE FRIENDS SKIPPING MEALS
ON A DAILY BASIS AND CONSUMING
DIET PILLS IN AN ATTEMPT TO
ACHIEVE THIS, THIS BODY NOT
KNOWING THE CONSEQUENCES THAT IT
HAS ON THEM. AT SEVERAL POINTS,
I CONSIDER TAKING SUPPLEMENTS SO
I COULD ACHIEVE A SO-CALLED
BETTER BODY. AND AT TIMES MY
PEERS WHO WERE UNAWARE OF
POTENTIAL RISKS EVEN ENCOURAGED
ME TO TAKE DIETARY SUPPLEMENTS.
THESE ARE THIS IS. THIS STORY
CAN BE SEEN IN MILLIONS OF
CALIFORNIAN YOUTH WHO LACK THIS
VITAL KNOWLEDGE AND AS A RESULT,
TURN TO DIET PILLS IN HOPES OF
QUICKLY ACHIEVING A CERTAIN BODY
TYPE. THESE ARE THE CHILDREN WHO
URGENTLY NEED PROTECTION FROM
THE DECEPTIVE WEIGHT LOSS
INDUSTRY. AB 82 IS CRUCIAL TO
SHIELD THE YOUTH OF CALIFORNIA
FROM THESE DANGEROUS DIET PILLS
AND WEIGHT LOSS SUPPLEMENTS BY
PREVENTING THESE COMPANIES FROM
PROFITING OFF OF AND EXPLOITING
THE INSECURITIES OF YOUNG
CHILDREN. THANK YOU FOR TAKING
THE TIME TO LISTEN TO MY
CONCERNS, AND I HOPE THAT MY,
EFFORTS WILL INSPIRE FURTHER
ACTION TO KEEP DIET PILLS OUT OF
KIDS HANDS. AND I URGE YOU TO
VOTE IN FAVOR OF AB 82. THANK
YOU. EXCELLENT PRESENTATION.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US. NEXT,
PLEASE. GOOD AFTERNOON.
HONORABLE MEMBERS OF THE
CALIFORNIA SENATE HEALTH
COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS ALI EVANS.
I'M A SISTER AND AN ADVOCATE FOR
A LOVED ONE WITH AN EATING
DISORDER. AND I'M HERE TODAY TO
URGE YOU TO SUPPORT ASSEMBLY
BILL 82. AT JUST 13 YEARS OLD, I
BEGAN MAKING CONTENT ONLINE. I
QUICKLY CULTIVATED AN AUDIENCE
OF HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS, AND
THOUGH THE OPPORTUNITIES THAT
CAME ALONG WITH THAT CHANGED MY
LIFE IN PROFOUND WAYS, THE
LASTING IMPLICATIONS OF GROWING
UP ONLINE DIDN'T BECOME CLEAR
UNTIL I ENTERED MY LATE 20S. I
RATIONALIZED THE THINGS THAT I
EXPERIENCED BECAUSE I WAS A
CHILD. MY ABILITY TO DISCERN
HARMFUL OR EXPLOITIVE
ENVIRONMENTS WAS IMPAIRED BY MY
LACK OF LIFE PERSPECTIVE. THAT'S
WHY I DID NOT FIND IT ODD OR
MANIPULATIVE. WHEN BRANDS LIKE
SKINNY TIME, TÊ AND OTHER DETOX
SUPPLEMENT BRANDS REACHED OUT TO
ME, OFFERING THOUSANDS OF
DOLLARS TO PROMOTE THEIR WEIGHT
LOSS SUPPLEMENTS, TEAS AND
GUMMIES TO MY HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF FOLLOWERS, MOST OF
WHICH WERE BETWEEN THE AGES OF
12 TO 16. JUST LIKE ME AT THE
TIME. LUCKILY, I HAD A TEAM OF
ADULTS BEHIND ME THAT PASSED ON
CAMPAIGNS LIKE THIS, BUT NOW,
LOOKING BACK AS AN ADULT, IT IS
BONE CHILLING TO REALIZE THAT
THESE PRODUCTS ARE NOT JUST
ACCESSIBLE TO CHILDREN, BUT THEY
ARE STRATEGICALLY MARKETED AND
TARGETED TO KIDS BY ADULTS. IN
THE FALL OF 2021, MY 12 YEAR OLD
SISTER BILLIE WAS DIAGNOSED WITH
ANOREXIA NERVOSA. THERE WERE
MANY FACTORS THAT LED TO THE
DEVELOPMENT OF HER EATING
DISORDER, BUT WE NOW KNOW THAT
SOCIAL MEDIA PLAYED A MAJOR ROLE
IN HER OBSESSIVE THOUGHT
PATTERNS AROUND EATING AND
WEIGHT LOSS. HER SOCIAL MEDIA
ACCOUNTS FOR YOU PAGES WERE
FLOODED WITH UNSOLICITED WEIGHT
LOSS VIDEOS CREATED BY
UNQUALIFIED FITNESS INFLUENCERS.
MANY OF WHICH WERE PEDDLING THE
SAME SUPPLEMENTS, TEAS AND
GUMMIES THAT BRANDS HAD TRIED TO
MAKE ME PROMOTE AS A KID.
CALIFORNIA'S KIDS DESERVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ENJOY THEIR
CHILDHOODS WITHOUT BEING
TARGETED BY WEIGHT LOSS BRANDS.
AS ACCESS TO THESE PRODUCTS,
ALONG WITH ROUND THE CLOCK
ADVERTISEMENTS FOR WEIGHT LOSS,
ARE FOREVER CHANGING THEIR SENSE
OF SELF AND THEIR RELATIONSHIPS
WITH THEIR BODIES. THIS IS WHY I
AM IN SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY BILL
82, A BILL THAT, IF PASSED,
WOULD REGULATE THE SALE OF
DIETARY SUPPLEMENTS FOR WEIGHT
LOSS AND OVER THE COUNTER PILLS
FOR MINORS. I SUPPORT THIS BILL
BECAUSE CHILDREN DO NOT HAVE THE
ABILITY TO COMPREHEND THE IMPACT
THAT THESE SUPPLEMENTS WILL HAVE
ON THEIR HEALTH AND THEIR
DEVELOPMENT. LEGISLATION IS
NEEDED TO PROTECT KIDS BECAUSE
THE BRANDS BEHIND THESE
SUPPLEMENTS HAVE NO PLANS TO
STOP TARGETING OUR KIDS WITH
MANIPULATIVE AND MISLEADING
MARKETING. AND FOR THAT REASON,
I AM URGING YOU TO PASS ASSEMBLY
BILL 82. THANK YOU. AND THANK
YOU FOR JOINING US AS WELL. YES,
MA'AM. HI. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TALK TO YOU. MY
NAME IS SONYA FRAUSTO. I'M A
PHARMACIST FOR 20 YEARS, AND I
HEAR THESE STORIES AND I'M LIKE,
OH MY GOSH, I CURRENTLY OWN TEN
ACRES PHARMACY HERE IN
SACRAMENTO, CALIFORNIA. WE DO
NOT STOCK DIETARY SUPPLEMENTS.
WE ARE LOCATED ABOUT A MILE AND
A HALF FROM A MIDDLE SCHOOL AND
A MILE AND A HALF FROM HIGH
SCHOOL. I'M JUST HEARING YOUR
STORIES AND I'M JUST THINKING,
WOW, CURRENTLY, WE ARE SEEING AN
UPTICK OF TEENAGERS HAVING
MULTIPLE PSYCHIATRIC ISSUES
REQUIRING ANTIDEPRESSANTS, MOOD
DISORDER MEDICATIONS, AND WHEN
WE HAVE SUPPLEMENTS LIKE THIS,
THERE ARE POTENTIAL DRUG DRUG
INTERACTIONS THAT THEY MIGHT NOT
NECESSARILY BE AWARE OF. AND FOR
THEM TO BE ABLE TO GO BUY THESE
THESE NON-PRESCRIPTION PRODUCTS
OVER THE COUNTER WITHOUT THE
CONSULTATION OF A PHARMACIST
LIKE MYSELF, I AM NOT ABLE TO
HELP DETERMINE WHAT POTENTIAL
SIDE EFFECTS THESE KIDS COULD
HAVE. THEY COULD BE CARDIAC
ISSUES. THERE COULD BE MENTAL
ISSUES. OBVIOUSLY, SELF-ESTEEM
ISSUES THAT ALL PHARMACISTS HAVE
THE ABILITY TO ADDRESS WHEN
PROPERLY. WHEN A PATIENT
PROPERLY COMES TO THEM AND ASKS
THEM FOR THESE MEDICATIONS,
PHARMACIST S CURRENTLY HAVE
SEVERAL PRESCRIPTIONS THAT
REQUIRE AN ID, DEXTROMETHORPHAN
OR ROBITUSSIN COUGH AND COLD
MEDICATIONS. PSEUDOEPHEDRINE.
ALL OF THOSE REQUIRE AN ID TO BE
PURCHASED FOR PATIENTS UNDER THE
AGE OF 18. AND THIS ALLOWS NOT
ONLY THEIR PARENTS, BUT ALLOWS
THE PHARMACIST TO HAVE DIRECT
INTERACTIONS WITH THESE CHILDREN
. SO THAT WAY WE CAN DETERMINE
IF THIS IS THE CORRECT
MEDICATION FOR THEM. SO WHEN
DIETARY SUPPLEMENTS ARE ABLE TO
EASILY BE SOLD ANYWHERE WHERE
WITHOUT THE PURVIEW OF A
PHARMACIST OR THE RESTRICTION OF
AN ID, IT PUTS OUR TEENS AT RISK
FOR A HOST OF ISSUES, FROM
CARDIAC TO MENTAL BODY IMAGES,
THAT WE THEN HAVE TO INCREASE
THE COST OF HEALTH CARE. SO I
URGE YOU, AS A PHARMACIST, AS A
BUSINESS OWNER, AS A MOM
LISTENING TO THESE STORIES,
PLEASE SUPPORT AB 82. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, THANKS FOR COMING AND
THANKS FOR YOUR TESTIMONY. ARE
THERE ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE? IF SO,
PLEASE STEP FORWARD. NAME,
AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON THE
MEASURE ONLY. PLEASE GOOD
MORNING, MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
ROBERT MURRAY, CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE, IN A
TWEENER POSITION, JUST WANT TO
MAKE ON THE RECORD THAT WE HAVE
REMOVED OUR OPPOSITION DUE TO
RECENT AMENDS, WHICH WERE
APPRECIATED TO ALLOW US TO
ENFORCE THE POLICY EFFECTIVELY.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU. ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT? SEEING
NONE. ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS MEASURE,
PLEASE STEP FORWARD. YOU MAY
TAKE A CHAIR AT THE TABLE IF
YOU'D LIKE. GOOD AFTERNOON.
CHAIR MEMBERS ARE YOU ABLE TO
HEAR ME? THERE WE GO, ANTHONY
SAMSON WITH SAMSON ADVISORS HERE
ON BEHALF OF THE COUNCIL FOR
RESPONSIBLE NUTRITION. CRNS THE
LEADING TRADE ASSOCIATION
REPRESENTING DIETARY SUPPLEMENT
AND FUNCTIONAL FOOD
MANUFACTURERS AND INGREDIENT
SUPPLIERS. FOR STARTERS, CRN IS
VERY MUCH ALIGNED WITH THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS GOALS OF
ADDRESSING EATING DISORDERS
AMONG YOUNG ADULTS. CRN'S
MEMBERS ADHERE TO A STRICT CODE
OF ETHICS, OBSERVE ALL FEDERAL
REQUIREMENTS FOR QUALITY
MANUFACTURING, AND ASSURE THAT
THE CLAIMS FOR THEIR PRODUCTS
ARE BOTH TRUTHFUL AND LAWFUL. TO
BE CLEAR, CRN MEMBERS DO NOT
MAKE MANUFACTURE OR MARKET
PRODUCTS WITH UNSAFE OR ILLEGAL
INGREDIENTS LIKE STEROIDS OR
UNAPPROVED DRUGS. WHEN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GARCIA INITIALLY
INTRODUCED THIS BILL IN THE FORM
OF AB 1341 A FEW YEARS AGO, CRN
NOTED THAT IT WAS OPPOSED TO
BLANKET RESTRICTIONS ON THE SALE
OF DIETARY SUPPLEMENTS, ABSENT
SCIENTIFIC EVIDENCE OF CAUSATION
TO HEALTH RISK. TO THAT POINT,
WE RAISED AT THAT TIME THAT
THERE WAS NO CREDIBLE SCIENTIFIC
CAUSAL LINK BETWEEN CRN MEMBERS
PRODUCTS AND EATING DISORDERS.
THAT SAID, ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GARCIA AND HER STAFF WORKED
PRODUCTIVELY WITH US AT THE TIME
TO DEVELOP A SOLUTION, ALBEIT AN
IMPERFECT ONE. ULTIMATELY,
GOVERNOR NEWSOM VETOED THAT
MEASURE AND NOTED THAT THE
REQUIREMENTS THAT THIS BILL
IMPOSED ON CDF WERE BEYOND THE
SCOPE OF THEIR CAPABILITIES.
SINCE THE VETO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WEBER AND HAS INTRODUCED THIS
MEASURE, AND WE VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THE MEMBER AND HER
STAFF'S OPEN DOOR POLICY. SINCE
THAT TIME. IN THOSE DISCUSSIONS
DISCUSSIONS, WE'VE REITERATED
CERTAIN CONCERNS, INCLUDING WITH
THE WARNING REQUIREMENT AS THE
ASSEMBLY JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS NOTED, WHEN IT ANALYZED
THE WARNING. THIS WARNING
LANGUAGE FOR AB 1341, THE
WARNING LANGUAGE MAY RAISE FIRST
AMENDMENT IMPLICATIONS BECAUSE
IT AMOUNTS TO COMPELLED SPEECH
THAT DISPARAGES LEGITIMATE
PRODUCTS WITH INFORMATION THAT
IS NOT FACTUAL OR WITHOUT
CONTROVERSY. IN SOME CRN
EXPRESSES OUR CONTINUED DESIRE
TO WORK WITH THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
TO FURTHER ASSIST HER EFFORTS TO
COMBAT THE SERIOUS PUBLIC HEALTH
PROBLEM OF EATING DISORDERS
AMONG OUR YOUTH. BUT WE DO HAVE
SOME OUTSTANDING CONCERNS. WE
WELCOME THE OPPORTUNITY TO
NARROWLY TAILOR A BILL THAT
WOULD CAPTURE ILLEGAL, DANGEROUS
PRODUCTS WHILE ENSURING THAT
SAFE AND LEGITIMATELY LEGITIMATE
DIETARY PRODUCTS REMAIN
AVAILABLE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
FOR JOINING US. ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO THE
MEASURE? PLEASE STEP FORWARD.
SEEING NONE, BRINGING THE MATTER
BACK TO THE DAIS AND MY
COLLEAGUES, COLLEAGUES, ANY
COMMENTS, QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS?
SENATOR MENGIBAR, ASSEMBLY
MEMBER, THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
BRINGING THIS LEGISLATION
FORWARD. YOU KNOW, THERE'S AN
IMAGE THAT I SAW MAYBE TEN, 15
YEARS AGO ON SOCIAL MEDIA. IT
WAS A YOUNG GIRL, WHO WAS
HOLDING A BIT OF HER BELLY FAT
WITH SCISSORS ABOUT TO CUT IT.
AND IN FRONT OF HER WERE
MAGAZINES AND SO FORTH. BECAUSE
NOW, TEN YEARS LATER, WE KNOW
WHAT SOCIAL MEDIA IS DOING A LOT
TO OUR SELF-ESTEEM OF OUR YOUTH
AND SO FORTH. SO I ALSO WANT TO
COMMEND YOUR WITNESSES FOR
COMING, BRINGING YOUTH TO THE
FOREFRONT OF THIS CONVERSATION,
BECAUSE THIS IS IMPACTING YOU AS
YOUTH. I THINK YOU SHOULD BE
PART OF THIS CONVERSATION. AND
WE'RE NOT JUST HERE TO PUSH
LEGISLATION BECAUSE WE WANT TO.
IT'S BECAUSE WE'RE HEARING FROM
INDIVIDUALS THAT IT'S GREATLY
IMPACTING. SO THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR THIS LEGISLATION. AND WHEN
APPROPRIATE, I'D LIKE TO MOVE
THE BILL. THANK YOU. SENATOR.
COLLEAGUES, ANY OTHER COMMENTS,
QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS SEEING
NONE. DOCTOR WEBER, WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE? OH THANK YOU
CHAIR, FIRST I WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR LOOKING AND
WORKING ON THIS BILL. I
DEFINITELY HAVE TO THANK MY
WITNESSES. THIS WAS A DYNAMIC
TRIO THAT I HAVE UP HERE TODAY.
AND, YOU KNOW, IF ANYONE CAN SIT
HERE AND SAY THAT IN CALIFORNIA,
WE SHOULDN'T DO SOMETHING AT
THIS POINT TO, TO STOP OUR MOST
VULNERABLE FROM HAVING ACCESS,
FREE ACCESS TO THESE SUPPLEMENTS
. THEY NEED TO LISTEN TO THESE
THREE INDIVIDUALS RIGHT HERE. SO
THANK YOU ALL SO MUCH, YOU KNOW,
WE'LL CONTINUE TO, TO WORK WITH
OPPOSITION, BUT THE REALITY IS
THAT IT, YOU KNOW, THESE ARE,
THINGS SUPPLEMENTS THAT ARE OUR
YOUTH SHOULD NOT BE TAKING AND
NOT HAVE ACCESS TO IT TO JUST GO
INTO A STORE AND GET IT OFF THE
COUNTER. BECAUSE ESSENTIALLY
WHAT WE'RE SAYING IS THAT THERE,
IF YOU DO THAT, THERE ARE NO
HARMFUL EFFECTS. AND WE CANNOT
SAY THAT, FOR OUR MOST
VULNERABLE AND SO WE'LL CONTINUE
TO WORK WITH THEM TO ENSURE THAT
WE HAVE A BILL, THAT, YOU KNOW,
THE GOVERNOR WOULD SIGN THIS
TIME. SO THAT WE CAN REALLY
PROTECT OUR ADOLESCENTS. AND
WITH THAT, I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE ON AB 82. THANK
YOU. DOCTOR, AS SOON AS WE
ESTABLISH A QUORUM, WE'LL TAKE A
MOTION AND TAKE A VOTE. THANK
YOU ALL. DOCTOR WEBER, WOULD YOU
LIKE TO PROCEED WITH ITEM NUMBER
THREE, AB 2250 SOCIAL
DETERMINANTS OF HEALTH. ALL
RIGHT. CHAIR. AND MEMBERS OF THE
HEALTH COMMITTEE. SENATE HEALTH
COMMITTEE, I'M HERE TO PRESENT
AB 2250, WHICH WILL REQUIRE
HEALTH PLANS AND INSURERS TO
INCLUDE COVERAGE FOR SOCIAL
DETERMINANTS OF HEALTH SCREENING
AND ACCESS TO COMMUNITY HEALTH
WORKERS. AND I WILL BE ACCEPTING
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR THOSE. SOCIAL
DETERMINANTS OF HEALTH ARE
COMMONLY DEFINED AS THE
CONDITIONS IN WHICH PEOPLE ARE
BORN, GROW, WORK, LIVE AND AGE
IN A WIDER SET OF FORCES AND
SYSTEMS. SHAPES THE CONDITIONS
OF DAILY LIFE AND AFFECT HEALTH,
FUNCTION AND QUALITY OF LIFE.
OUTCOMES AND RISK. SD0 IMPACTS
ABOUT 80% OF YOUR HEALTH RISK,
HEALTH OUTCOMES AND
UNFORTUNATELY, YOUR LIFE
EXPECTANCY. IT IS ABSOLUTELY
HORRIFIC THAT IN THIS COUNTRY
AND IN THIS STATE, YOU CAN GO ON
THE WEBSITE AND TYPE IN YOUR ZIP
CODE AND THAT WILL GIVE YOU YOUR
LIFE EXPECTANCY. SOCIAL
DETERMINANT OF HEALTH SCREENING
TOOLS AND CLINICAL PRACTICE HELP
IDENTIFY THESE SOCIAL AND
ECONOMIC RISK FACTORS OF
PATIENTS THAT ARE USUALLY
UNKNOWN TO US, WHO ARE HEALTH
CARE PROVIDERS, BUT THEY ARE A
CRITICAL PIECE AND OFTEN THE
MISSING LINK TO SUCCESS.
SUCCESSFULLY PREVENTING OR
MANAGING HEALTH CONDITION IS.
SCREENING FOR SD0 ARE EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT, AND THIS INFORMATION
CAN LEAD TO HEALTH TEAMS
CREATING BETTER HEALTH
OPPORTUNITIES AND PLANS FOR
THEIR PATIENTS. AB 2250 SERVES
AS A PROACTIVE SOLUTION TO THESE
CHALLENGES AND HELPS ADDRESS
GAPS IN HEALTH CARE BY REQUIRING
COVERAGE AND REIMBURSEMENT FOR
SOCIAL DETERMINANT OF HEALTH
SCREENING AND ACCESS TO
COMMUNITY HEALTH WORKERS. WHILE
A SIMILAR BILL WAS VETOED LAST
YEAR, DESPITE WHAT THE GOVERNOR
SAID IN HIS VETO MESSAGE, THIS
BILL IS NOT REDUNDANT TO FEDERAL
INITIATIVES, NOR ARE ADVERSE
CHILDHOOD EXPERIENCE SCREENINGS
THE SAME AS SOCIAL DETERMINANT
OF HEALTH SCREENINGS. IN REGARDS
TO THE QUESTION OF REDUNDANCY TO
FEDERAL INITIATIVES, THESE NEW
EFFORTS BY THE CENTERS FOR
MEDICARE AND MEDICAID SERVICES
ARE ONLY WITHIN THE MEDICARE
SYSTEM AND DO NOT CONFLICT WITH
AB 2250, WHICH TARGETS THE
MEDI-CAL AND COVERED CALIFORNIA
POPULATION. AND WHILE ACS CAN BE
CONSIDERED ONE ASPECT OF SOCIAL
DETERMINANTS OF HEALTH, THEY
THEY REPRESENT A SPECIFIC SUBSET
OF ADVERSE CHILDHOOD EXPERIENCES
THAT CAN INFLUENCE HEALTH
OUTCOMES. SOCIAL DETERMINANTS OF
HEALTH, ON THE OTHER HAND,
ENCOMPASS A BROADER RANGE OF
SOCIAL AND ENVIRONMENTAL FACTORS
THAT INFLUENCE THE HEALTH AND
WELL-BEING THROUGHOUT A PERSON'S
ENTIRE LIFE. BY REQUIRING
COVERAGE FOR SCREENING AND
ACCESS TO COMMUNITY HEALTH
WORKERS. AB 2250 ENSURE THAT
MEDI-CAL BENEFICIARIES BENEFIT
FROM THESE ESSENTIAL SERVICES.
ADDITIONALLY IT EXTENDS SUPPORT
BEYOND THE MEDI-CAL POPULATION
TO INCLUDE OTHER VULNERABLE
GROUPS SUCH AS THOSE UNDER
COVERED CALIFORNIA WHO ALSO FACE
SOCIAL NEEDS BUT MAY NOT HAVE
ACCESS TO THOSE SERVICES
PREVIOUSLY WITH ME HERE TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF AB 85 ARE TYISHA
WATTS CAP LEGISLATIVE AND POLICY
ADVOCATE AND DOCTOR ROBERT
ASHBY, FAMILY PHYSICIAN AT SAN
JOAQUIN GENERAL HOSPITAL. THANK
YOU. WELCOME. THANK YOU FOR
JOINING US. PLEASE PROCEED WHEN
READY. PLEASE INTRODUCE
YOURSELVES. FOR THE RECORD.
OKAY. GOOD AFTERNOON, CHAIRMAN
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS. MY NAME
IS DOCTOR ROBERT ASHBY, AND I'M
A FAMILY MEDICINE PHYSICIAN
PRACTICING IN SAN JOAQUIN
GENERAL HOSPITAL IN STOCKTON,
CALIFORNIA. I AM HERE TODAY TO
SHARE WHY I PASSIONATELY
ADVOCATE FOR THE INCLUSION OF
SOCIAL DETERMINANTS OF HEALTH IN
OUR HEALTH CARE APPROACH TO
ADDRESS THE NEEDS OF VULNERABLE
PATIENTS OUTSIDE THE CLINIC
WALLS. AS A PHYSICIAN, I SEE
FIRSTHAND HOW CRITICAL IT IS TO
UNDERSTAND THE BROADER CONTEXT
OF MY PATIENT LIVES. FOR
INSTANCE, I FACILITATE A STREET
MEDICINE CLINIC WHERE WE PROVIDE
HEALTH CARE TO THE UNHOUSED
POPULATION. IN ONE CASE, I HAD A
PATIENT WITH HEART FAILURE WHO
WAS EXTREMELY TEARFUL BECAUSE
HIS MEDICATIONS WOULD ALWAYS GET
STOLEN FROM THE ENCAMPMENT WHERE
HE STAYED. WORSE YET, HE DIDN'T
WANT TO TAKE HIS WATER PILL
ANYMORE FOR THE FEAR OF
CONSTANTLY URINATING ON HIMSELF
AS HE WAS UNABLE TO WALK AND HE
WAS IN A WHEELCHAIR DUE TO HIS
LEG SWELLING AND PAIN. I HAD TO
NAVIGATE HOW TO TREAT HIM WITH A
SPECIFIC DOSE. TIMING OF HIS
MEDICATION ONE WEEK PRESCRIPTION
AT A TIME AND HAVE IT DELIVERED
TO THE CHURCH WHERE I WAS
TREATING HIM AT. HAD HE BEEN
SCREENED EARLIER FOR SOCIAL
DETERMINANTS OF HEALTH, HIS
OUTCOME MAY HAVE BEEN DIFFERENT.
AB 2250 WOULD PROVIDE THE
RESOURCES NECESSARY TO SCREEN
OUR PATIENTS EARLY AND HELP US
AS PHYSICIANS, IDENTIFY THE
SOCIAL NEEDS THAT CAN CAUSE
UNNECESSARY HEALTH CARE
COMPLEXITIES DOWN THE LINE. YET
SCREENING FOR THESE SOCIAL
DETERMINANTS IS ONLY THE
BEGINNING. MANY OF THE PATIENTS
FACE BARRIERS BEYOND THE CLINIC
THAT HINDER THEIR ABILITY TO
FOLLOW THROUGH WITH THEIR
TREATMENT PLANS, LIKE MY
PATIENT. AB 2250 ADDRESSES THE
GAPS BY BRIDGING HEALTH CARE
WITH ESSENTIAL COMMUNITY
RESOURCES THROUGH THE SUPPORT OF
COMMUNITY HEALTH WORKERS AND
SOCIAL WORKERS, THESE
PROFESSIONALS CAN CONNECT
PATIENTS WITH NECESSARY SERVICES
SUCH AS FOOD, TRANSPORTATION,
HOUSING, HEALTH CARE AND ENSURE
THEY RECEIVE COMPREHENSIVE AND
CONTINUOUS CARE FOR EXAMPLE, I
HAD ANOTHER PATIENT WHO WAS
DIAGNOSED WITH HIV AND COULD NOT
GET HER LABS PERFORMED TO
ACCURATELY MONITOR HER TREATMENT
PLAN. WHEN I WAS ABLE TO CONNECT
HER WITH A COMMUNITY HEALTH
WORKER WHO LOOKED LIKE HER, TALK
LIKE HER, AND UNDERSTOOD HER
ENVIRONMENT, WERE WE THEN ABLE
TO GET HER SCHEDULED FOR HER
LABS AND APPROPRIATELY MANAGED
HER CARE? THIS BILL IS A CRUCIAL
STEP TOWARD A MORE HOLISTIC
HEALTH CARE SYSTEM THAT TRULY
MEETS THE NEEDS OF OUR
COMMUNITIES. I RESPECTFULLY URGE
YOU TO VOTE YES ON AB 2250.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU DOCTOR.
NEXT PLEASE. HI. GOOD AFTERNOON,
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS THIS
CRITICAL ISSUE. MY NAME IS
TAISHA WATTS, REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF FAMILY
PHYSICIANS. ADDRESSING PATIENT
SOCIOECONOMIC NEEDS IS ESSENTIAL
FOR IMPROVING HEALTH OUTCOMES.
ISSUES LIKE LACK OF FOOD,
HOUSING, CLEAN WATER,
TRANSPORTATION, AND EMPLOYMENT
SIGNIFICANTLY IMPACT HEALTH,
ESPECIALLY FOR THOSE WITH
CHRONIC CONDITIONS. ISSUES LIKE.
TAKE, FOR EXAMPLE, PATIENTS WITH
TYPE TWO DIABETES WITHOUT ACCESS
TO AFFORDABLE MEDICATION OR
HEALTHY GROCERIES. MANAGING THE
A-1C LEVELS BECOMES A DIFFICULT
TASK. THE RATIONALE FOR
SCREENING FOR SOCIAL
DETERMINANTS OF HEALTH IS SIMPLE
IF YOU DON'T ASK, YOU WON'T KNOW
AND IF YOU DON'T KNOW ABOUT A
PATIENT'S SOCIAL NEEDS, YOU
CANNOT ADDRESS THEM AND PROVIDE
THE BEST CARE. DESPITE PROGRESS
WITH INITIATIVES LIKE THE
COMMUNITY HEALTH WORKER BENEFIT
UNDER MEDI-CAL AND SOCIAL
DETERMINANTS OF HEALTH
DIAGNOSTIC CODES UNDER CALAIM,
THERE ARE STILL GAPS THAT AB
2250 SEEKS TO FILL. PRIMARY CARE
PROVIDERS FACE BARRIERS IN
COLLECTING AND DOCUMENTING
SOCIAL DETERMINANTS OF HEALTH
DATA, AND WITHOUT PROPER
RESOURCES AND REIMBURSEMENT,
THEY CANNOT EFFECTIVELY CONDUCT
SCREENINGS OR CONNECT PATIENTS
TO NECESSARY RESOURCES. AS THE
FIRST AND OFTEN MOST CONSISTENT
POINT OF CONTACT IN THE HEALTH
CARE SYSTEM, SOCIAL DETERMINANTS
OF HEALTH SCREENINGS ARE
TYPICALLY CONDUCTED BY PRIMARY
CARE PHYSICIANS. HOWEVER,
MEDI-CAL DOES NOT CURRENTLY
REIMBURSE THEM FOR THESE
SERVICES. AB 2250 PROPOSES
COVERING SOCIAL DETERMINANTS OF
HEALTH SCREENING AND THE PRIMARY
CARE SETTING, ENSURING EQUITABLE
ACCESS TO ESSENTIAL HEALTH
SERVICES. THE BILL ALSO BRIDGES
GAPS BETWEEN MEDICAL CARE AND
THE VITAL ROLE OF COMMUNITY
HEALTH WORKERS PROVIDE, AND
PROVIDING SOCIAL SUPPORTS AND
SERVICES BY LINKING PATIENTS
WITH COMMUNITY HEALTH WORKERS,
WE CAN ADDRESS UNMET SOCIAL
NEEDS AND IMPROVE HEALTH
OUTCOMES AND EQUITY. SIGNIFICANT
INVESTMENTS HAVE BEEN MADE TO
STRENGTHEN THE COMMUNITY HEALTH
WORKER WORKFORCE, INCLUDING
RECRUITMENT, TRAINING AND
CERTIFICATION. HEALTH PLANS AND
INSURERS ALSO PLAY A KEY ROLE IN
THESE EFFORTS, EITHER THROUGH
PARTNERSHIPS WITH COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATIONS OR EMPLOYING
COMMUNITY HEALTH WORKERS
DIRECTLY WITH THE BILLS
IMPLEMENTATION DATE IN 2027, WE
ANTICIPATE AN EVEN MORE ROBUST
COMMUNITY HEALTH WORKER
WORKFORCE READY TO SERVE
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS, AND
CLOSING AB 2250 IS VITAL FOR
ADDRESSING SOCIAL DETERMINANTS
OF HEALTH AND ADVANCING HEALTH
EQUITY. I URGE YOUR SUPPORT FOR
THIS LEGISLATION. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME AND CONSIDERATION, AND
I AM AVAILABLE TO ACCEPT ANY
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION. ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT, NAME,
AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON THE
MEASURE ONLY, PLEASE. CHAIR.
SENATOR STEINKE RAFEAL WITH
CAPITAL ADVOCACY HERE ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA LIFE SCIENCES
IN SUPPORT OF AB 20. THANK YOU.
NEXT, PLEASE, MR. CHAIR. MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE, MARK OPREA, ON
BEHALF OF CHILDREN'S CHOICE,
URGE YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU.
NEXT, MR. CHAIR, AND MEMBERS,
RAND MARTIN, ON BEHALF OF THE
AIDS HEALTHCARE FOUNDATION AND
VERY STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL. THANK YOU. THANK YOU SIR.
NEXT, PLEASE. ISABELLA ARGUETA
WITH THE HEALTH OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. KELLY LARUE,
FOR THE CALIFORNIA KIDNEY CARE
ALLIANCE IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU,
TIM MADDEN, REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER OF THE
AMERICAN COLLEGE OF EMERGENCY
PHYSICIANS IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU, SIR. BRIAN SPENCER, ON
BEHALF OF OCEAN AND THE AMERICAN
COLLEGE OF OBGYNS, DISTRICT
NINE, IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU SIR.
NEXT, PLEASE. JENNIFER ROBLES
WITH HEALTH ACCESS CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT. THANKS GOOD AFTERNOON,
SANDRA POOL, WESTERN CENTER FOR
LAW AND POVERTY AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU, A.B. ALVAREZ, ON
BEHALF OF ESSENTIAL ACCESS
HEALTH, APLA HEALTH AND LOCAL
HEALTH PLANS OF CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU, THANK YOU.
NEXT, PLEASE, MR. CHAIR, AND
MEMBERS, DENNIS CUEVAS ROMERO
WITH THE CALIFORNIA PRIMARY CARE
ASSOCIATION ADVOCATES PROUD TO
CO-SPONSOR OF THE BILL. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU, SIR. NEXT,
PLEASE. YES, MA'AM. HELLO. MOLLY
ROBSON WITH PLANNED PARENTHOOD
AFFILIATES OF CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON. KELLY MCMILLAN. ON
BEHALF OF TWO CLIENTS,
CHILDREN'S SPECIALTY CARE
COALITION AND DAVITA. THANK YOU.
YES, MA'AM. HELLO. MARISA
MONTANO WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ACADEMY OF FAMILY PHYSICIANS
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF OUR
CO-SPONSORS WHO COULDN'T MAKE
THE HEARING, THE CALIFORNIA
BLACK HEALTH NETWORK IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. MA'AM. YES, SIR. MR.
CHAIR, MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE,
BRANDON MAKI WITH THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. ANY OTHER WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT NOW, LET'S TURN TO
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION? FIRST
LEAD OPPOSITION. OKAY. SEEING
NONE. ANY OTHER WITNESSES WHO
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO
THIS MEASURE? SEEING NONE. OKAY,
LET'S BRING THE MATTER BACK TO
THE DESK. COLLEAGUES, ANY
COMMENTS, QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS?
SENATOR RUBIO, YOU MAY START.
THANK YOU. I WANT TO THANK THE
GOOD DOCTOR HERE FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD. I THINK IT'S JUST
SUCH A GREAT INVESTMENT TO
TACKLE THESE ISSUES EARLY ON,
AND I KNOW I JUST YOU KNOW, IT
BRINGS ME BACK TO SOME OF THE
DAYS OF WHEN I WAS A TEACHER IN
THE CLASSROOM AND, YOU KNOW,
USED TO FOCUS ON SOME OF THE
THINGS THAT WE DISCOVERED LATER
ON IN LIFE WHEN WE USED TO SAY,
IF ONLY THEY HAD CAUGHT THIS
EARLY ON, LIKE THE DIFFERENCE IT
WOULD MAKE FOR CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES. AND SO I JUST DON'T
THINK IT'S THE FAMILY THAT'S,
BENEFITS FROM THIS. IT'S JUST
OUR ENTIRE COMMUNITY, OUR SCHOOL
DISTRICT. AND AT THE END OF THE
DAY, WE INVEST UP FRONT. SO THAT
WE DON'T HAVE TO TAKE CARE OF,
YOU KNOW, INCREDIBLE COSTS AT
THE END FOR FAMILIES. AND AGAIN,
JUST SIMPLY AS A SCHOOL TEACHER,
JUST THINKING OF WHAT IT DOES TO
CHILDREN SOMETIMES WHEN WE
CANNOT CATCH SOME OF THESE
THINGS THAT WE SHOULD HAVE AT
THE VERY BEGINNING. SO I WANT TO
SAY THANK YOU, AND I'M HAPPY TO
ADD, AS A COAUTHOR, APPRECIATE
YOU. THANK YOU. SENATOR. ANY
OTHER COMMENTS, QUESTIONS OR
CONCERNS? COLLEAGUES SEEING
NONE. DOCTOR. YES YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU. WELL, ONCE
AGAIN, I WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR YOUR WORK. AND
AGAIN, WE'LL BE ACCEPTING THE
AMENDMENTS. WANT TO THANK THOSE
WHO CAME AND SPOKE, TESTIFIED IN
SUPPORT AND ALSO ALL OF THOSE
WHO ARE IN SUPPORT. I WANT TO
THANK SENATOR RUBIO FOR HER
AMAZING COMMENTS, BUT SHE IS
100% CORRECT. A LOT OF THESE
THINGS WE CAN CATCH EARLY, THE
ONLY WAY THAT WE ARE REALLY,
TRULY GOING TO BE ABLE TO MAKE A
DENT IN CLOSING SOME OF THE
EQUITY GAPS WITHIN HEALTH AND IN
OUR COMMUNITIES, SOME OF THE
DISPARITIES THAT WE SEE IS TO
REALLY GET TO THE ROOT, AND A
LOT OF THAT HAS TO DO WITH THE
SOCIETAL ISSUES. AND AS
PROVIDERS, WE TRY TO DO OUR
BEST. WE HAVE CHANGED THE WAY IN
WHICH WE THINK. WHEN I WAS IN
MEDICAL SCHOOL, IN EARLY, EARLY
RESIDENCY, WE USED TO TALK ABOUT
THE NONCOMPLIANT PATIENT, RIGHT.
AND WE HAVE NOW SWITCHED THAT
THINKING INTO SAYING, WELL, WHY
IS THIS PATIENT LATE? Þ BECAUSE
THEY HAD TO TAKE TWO BUSSES HERE
, OR WHY IS THIS PATIENT NOT
TAKING THEIR MEDICATION? WELL,
BECAUSE THEY DON'T HAVE A
REFRIGERATOR TO HOLD THEIR
INSULIN AND SO WE HAVE SWITCHED
OUR THINKING. AND NOW IT'S TIME
FOR THE STATE TO SWITCH ITS
THINKING AND HOW WE TREAT AND WE
PAY FOR. AND WE LOOK AT OUR
PATIENTS TO SAY YES, WE MAY NEED
TO DO A LITTLE BIT MORE UPFRONT
TO PREVENT LONGER AND MORE
CHRONIC HEALTH CARE ISSUES AND
COSTS DOWN THE LINE. AND THIS IS
A BILL THAT WILL HELP US DO MORE
OF THAT PREVENTION. AND SO WITH
THAT, I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR VOTE ON AB 2250. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, DOCTOR. AS SOON AS WE
ESTABLISH A QUORUM, WE'LL TAKE A
MOTION AND WE'LL TAKE A VOTE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PRESENTATION.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE. NOW
LET'S TURN TO ITEM NUMBER 12, AB
3245. ASSEMBLY MEMBER PATTERSON,
COVERAGE FOR COLORECTAL CANCER
SCREENING. PROCEED WHEN READY.
SIR HI. AGAIN. THANK YOU, MISTER
CHAIR. SENATORS, I'M HERE TO
PRESENT AB 3245 AND I WILL BE
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS. AND REALLY
APPRECIATE THE WORK WITH MY TEAM
ON THIS PIECE OF LEGISLATION. AS
YOU MAY KNOW, THERE IS CURRENTLY
LITIGATION GOING ON IN TEXAS
THAT PUTS INTO JEOPARDY THE
COVERAGE OF COLORECTAL CANCER
SCREENING. AND SO WHAT MY
LEGISLATION DOES IS IT ENSURES
WE BRING IN A LITTLE BIT MORE OF
THAT CONTROL HERE IN CALIFORNIA
TO MAKE SURE WE DON'T, LOSE THAT
COVERAGE HERE FOR PEOPLE WHO
REALLY DEPEND ON IT. AND I'M
SURE, UNFORTUNATELY, MANY OF US
HAVE BEEN OR FRIENDS HAVE BEEN
IMPACTED BY THESE TYPES OF
CANCERS. IT'S VERY IMPORTANT. I
DON'T THINK, YOU KNOW, THERE'S
REALLY ANY DEBATE ON THAT. BUT
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE IF THE
LITIGATION, CAUSES PROBLEMS IN
TERMS OF THE COVERAGE, THAT WE
HAVE A SOLUTION HERE IN
CALIFORNIA TO MAKE SURE THAT
THESE SCREENINGS CAN CONTINUE
AND THAT LIVES CONTINUE TO BE
SAVED. AND SO WITH THAT HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS AND,
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU. SIR. IS THIS A YES? I
HAVE, DIRECTOR EMERITUS DEAN
GRAFILO WITH ME. PLEASE PROCEED
WHEN READY, SIR. CHAIR. ROSS.
SENATORS COMMITTEE STAFF TÍNH
RAFEAL WITH CAPITAL ADVOCACY ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA LIFE
SCIENCES, WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF
AB 3245, WHICH WOULD REQUIRE
HEALTH PLANS TO COVER COLORECTAL
COLORECTAL CANCER SCREENING.
CALIFORNIA LIFE SCIENCES
REPRESENTS OVER 1200 ENTITIES
REPRESENTING PHARMACEUTICAL,
BIOTECHNOLOGY, MEDICAL
TECHNOLOGY AND ACADEMIC RESEARCH
INSTITUTIONS THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA AFTER SKIN CANCER.
COLORECTAL CANCER IS THE THIRD
MOST COMMON CANCER DIAGNOSED IN
BOTH MEN AND WOMEN EACH YEAR IN
THE UNITED STATES. IN 2020,
THREE, OVER 150,000 ADULTS IN
THE UNITED STATES WERE DIAGNOSED
WITH COLORECTAL CANCER. THESE
NUMBERS INCLUDED OVER 106,000
NEW CASES OF COLON CANCER AND
OVER 46,000 NEW CASES OF RECTAL
CANCER. OVER 50,000 DEATHS FROM
THIS DISEASE OCCURRED IN THE
UNITED STATES JUST LAST YEAR
ALONE. HOWEVER, WHEN COLORECTAL
CANCER IS FOUND EARLY, IT CAN
OFTEN BE CURED. THE DEATH RATE
FROM THIS TYPE OF CANCER IN
2020. IN THE UNITED STATES WAS
57% LESS THAN IT WAS IN 1970,
DUE TO THE IMPROVEMENTS IN
TREATMENT AND INCREASED
SCREENING, WHICH DETECTS
COLORECTAL CHANGES BEFORE THEY
TURN CANCEROUS. THROUGH AB 3245,
CALIFORNIANS WILL HAVE INCREASED
ACCESS TO COLORECTAL CANCER
SCREENINGS THAT CAN POTENTIALLY
SAVE THEIR LIVES OR AT LEAST
CATCH THE CANCER EARLY ENOUGH TO
SAVE THE COST OF THE MOST
EXPENSIVE AND ARDUOUS LATE STAGE
TREATMENTS. FOR THESE REASONS,
CALIFORNIA LIFE SCIENCES
STRONGLY SUPPORTS AB 3245. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU FOR ATTENDING AND
FOR YOUR PRESENTATION, BEFORE WE
TAKE FURTHER SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION, LET'S ESTABLISH A
QUORUM. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SENATOR ROTH HERE, ROTH HERE.
WHEN I WHEN I'M HERE. SORRY.
WHEN HERE. GLASER GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ HERE. GROVE HURTADO.
LIMÓN. MENGIBAR MENGIBAR. HERE.
RUBIO. PRESENT. RUBIO PRESENT.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. WIENER. HERE
WIENER. HERE. WE HAVE A QUORUM.
THANK YOU. ANY OTHER WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE?
NAME, AFFILIATION AND POSITION
ON THE MEASURE ONLY. PLEASE
BRANDON MAKI WITH THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US. ANY
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT? ANY
OTHER WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION?
FIRST LEAD OPPOSITION. COME ON
DOWN.
MR. CHAIR, MEMBERS. STEPHANIE
WATKINS, ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA LIFE
AND HEALTH INSURANCE COMPANIES.
FIRST, I'D LIKE TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE AND THE AUTHOR AND THE
SPONSORS FOR THEIR OPEN DIALOG
ON THIS. ORIGINALLY, AB 3245
REQUIRED HEALTH PLAN CONTRACTS
AND HEALTH INSURANCE POLICIES TO
PROVIDE COVERAGE WITHOUT COST
SHARING FOR COLORECTAL CANCER
SCREENING ASSIGNED BY THE TASK
FORCE OR IN ACCORDANCE WITH THE
MOST CURRENT RECOMMENDED, WAS
ESTABLISHED BY ANOTHER
ACCREDITED OR CERTIFIED
GUIDELINE AGENCY. OUR PRIMARY
CONCERN WAS THAT THE BILL WAS
PROPOSING TO MOVE AWAY FROM
UTILIZING THE CURRENT TASK FORCE
STANDARD, AND REPLACING IT WITH
ANY RECOMMENDATION ESTABLISHED
BY ANOTHER ACCREDITED OR
CERTIFIED GUIDELINE AGENCY.
PREVIOUSLY, SEEING THE STANDARD
PROPOSED IN OTHER BILLS. AND IT
CERTAINLY GIVES US PAUSE AS IT
WOULD CREATE NOT ONLY
UNCERTAINTY IN THE MARKET, BUT
ALSO INCONSISTENCIES AS
INDIVIDUALS. PLANS COULD HAVE
DIFFERING VIEWS STANDARDS AS TO
WHAT SHOULD BE COVERED WITHOUT
COST SHARING. THAT BEING SAID,
WE MUCH APPRECIATE THE
COMMITTEE'S AMENDMENTS AND FEEL
THEY GO A LONG WAY TO ADDRESS
OUR CONCERNS. WE HAVE THOSE
CIRCULATING OUT TO OUR
MEMBERSHIP AND HOPE TO BE
REEVALUATING OUR POSITION IF THE
BILL MOVES FORWARD TODAY. THANK
YOU, THANK YOU. NEXT, SIR, GOOD
AFTERNOON, CHAIR. MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE, ROBERT BOYKIN WITH
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF HEALTH
PLANS. REGRETTABLY HERE TODAY,
IN OPPOSITION TO AB 3245, I
WOULD LIKE TO ECHO THE COMMENTS
OF ALEC WHO JUST WENT BEFORE ME.
WE WOULD ALSO LIKE TO ADD THAT
OUR CONCERNS STEMMED FROM THE
UNKNOWN PREMIUM IMPACT. SHOULD A
NEW NON-EVIDENCE BASED SCREENING
THAT IS INCONSISTENT WITH
NATIONAL STANDARDS BE COVERED
WITHOUT COST SHARE. WE ARE
THANKFUL FOR THE AMENDMENTS AS
WELL AND WILL BE REVIEWING OUR
POSITION AS THE BILL MOVES
FORWARD TODAY. THANK YOU ALSO
SIR. THANKS FOR BEING HERE.
THANK YOU. ANY OTHER WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION, MR. CHAIR
MEMBERS, JOHN WINGER, ON BEHALF
OF AMERICA'S HEALTH INSURANCE
PLANS, WOULD ECHO THE COMMENTS
OF CAP AND THANK YOU. ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION? SEEING
NONE. LET'S BRING THE MATTER
BACK TO MY COLLEAGUES ON THE
DESK. COLLEAGUES ANY COMMENTS,
QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS? LOOKING
RIGHT, LOOKING LEFT, SEEING NONE
. SOME MEMBER YOU MAY CLOSE.
WELL, THANK YOU VERY MUCH, YOU
KNOW, WHEN THIS WAS BROUGHT TO
MY ATTENTION, I WAS VERY
INTERESTED IN IT. I HAD A REALLY
GOOD FRIEND OF MINE WHO WAS
DIAGNOSED WITH COLON CANCER AT
40 YEARS OLD, FORTUNATELY,
BECAUSE OF SCREENING AND
DETECTION, HE HE JUST CELEBRATED
HIS 50TH BIRTHDAY, THREE YOUNG,
BEAUTIFUL CHILDREN. AND SO
BECAUSE OF THAT, GAVE ME THE
MOTIVATION TO DO THIS. BILL, I'M
VERY PLEASED TO, WORK WITH THE
COMMITTEE AND ALSO THE
OPPOSITION ON. AND I'M HOPEFUL
THAT WE'LL BE ABLE TO REMOVE THE
OPPOSITION. BUT IF NOT, I THINK
THIS IS AN IMPORTANT ISSUE AND
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH ANYBODY
THAT EXPRESSES CONCERN AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. NICE
PRESENTATION, THIS IS ASSEMBLY
BILL 3245. IS THERE A MOTION?
COLLEAGUES SO MOVED. SENATOR
WIENER MOVES THE BILL. PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL AND THE MOTION.
AND THE MOTION IS TO PASS, AS
AMENDED. AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
SENATOR ROTH, A ROTH I WHEN I
WHEN I GLASER. GLASER I
GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ I. GROVE.
GROVE. I. HURTADO HURTADO I
LIMÓN. LIMÓN I MENGIBAR. RUBIO
I. RUBIO. I. SMALLWOOD CUEVAS.
WIENER. WIENER. I VOTE IS NINE
ZERO. WILL HOLD THE WILL OPEN
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS. THANK GREAT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. LET'S
RETURN TO. ITEM NUMBER ONE AB
82, ASSEMBLY MEMBER WEBER.
DIETARY SUPPLEMENTS. THE MOTION
HAS BEEN MADE BY SENATOR
MENGIBAR. THE MOTION IS TO PASS.
WE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
JUDICIARY. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SENATOR ROTH A ROTH. AYE WHEN?
GLASER. GLASER I GONZALEZ I
GONZALEZ I GROVE. HURTADO.
HURTADO I LIMÓN. I LEMON. I
MENGIBAR. MENGIBAR. I RUBIO.
RUBIO. I SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS
WIENER. WIENER. I VOTE IS EIGHT
ZERO WILL HOLD THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS. LET'S TAKE UP
THE CONSENT CALENDAR. THE
CONSENT CALENDAR IS ITEM NUMBER
TWO AB 1943 WEBER MEDI-CAL
TELEHEALTH ITEM NUMBER FOUR AB
1792. ASSEMBLY MEMBER RODRIGUEZ.
EMERGENCY MEDICAL SERVICES, ITEM
NUMBER FIVE AB 2146 ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RODRIGUEZ. PRODUCT SAFETY
ITEM NUMBER SIX AB 1936 ASSEMBLY
MEMBER, CERVANTES. MATERNAL
MENTAL HEALTH SCREENINGS. ITEM
NUMBER SEVEN AB 2129 ASSEMBLY
MEMBER, PETRIE-NORRIS. IMMEDIATE
POSTPARTUM CONTRACEPTION. ITEM
NUMBER EIGHT AB 2131 ASSEMBLY
MEMBER, VALENCIA CERTIFIED NURSE
ASSISTANT TRAINING PROGRAMS WITH
AMENDMENTS ITEM NUMBER NINE AB
2154 ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN
MENTAL HEALTH IN INVOLUNTARY
TREATMENT. ITEM NUMBER TEN, AB
2556 ASSEMBLY MEMBER, JACKSON
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH AND WELLNESS
SCREENINGS WITH AMENDMENTS. ITEM
NUMBER 11, AB 2841. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WALDRON CONTROLLED
SUBSTANCES SUBSTANCES RESEARCH
ADVISORY PANEL URGENCY WITH
AMENDMENTS. IS THERE A MOTION ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR? SO WHEN
SENATOR NGUYEN MOVES THE CONSENT
CALENDAR, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SENATOR ROTH AYE. ROTH I WHEN I
WHEN I GLASER. GLASER I GONZALEZ
GONZALEZ I GROVE. GROVE I
HURTADO HURTADO I LIMÓN LIMÓN I
MENGIBAR MENGIBAR I RUBIO I
RUBIO I SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS WIENER
WIENER I CONSENT CALENDAR. THE
VOTE IS TEN ZERO WILL HOLD THE
ROLL OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
AND LET'S TAKE UP ITEM NUMBER
THREE ASSEMBLY BILL 2250.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WEBER. SOCIAL
DETERMINANTS OF HEALTH. THE
MOTION IS Dð PASS AS AMENDED AND
RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. IS THERE A
MOTION? SO MOVED. SENATOR
HURTADO MOVES THE MEASURE.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. SENATOR
ROTH. AYE. ROTH. AYE. WHEN
GLASER. GLASER. AYE. GONZALEZ
AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE
HURTADO. HURTADO. AYE. LIMÓN
LIMÓN. AYE. MENGIBAR MENGIBAR.
AYE. RUBIO. AYE. RUBIO AYE.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. WIENER.
WIENER AYE. GIVE EIGHT. YEP VOTE
IS EIGHT ZERO. WILL HOLD THE
ROLL OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
I GOTTA GET BACK TO MY COMMITTEE
. I'M SORRY, I DIDN'T I WAS. NO,
NO, NO, I KNOW, OKAY, LET'S OPEN
THE ROLL FIRST ON ITEM NUMBER
ONE, AB 82, ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WEBER. DIETARY SUPPLEMENTS. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AND RE REFER
TO THE COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY.
THE CURRENT VOTE IS EIGHT ZERO.
CHAIR VOTING. I MOVE BY SENATOR
MENGIBAR. PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL.
SENATOR NGUYEN GROVE SMALL
WOULD. CUEVAS. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS
I VOTE IS NINE ZERO. THAT BILL
IS OUT. LET'S MOVE TO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. ITEMS ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. ITEM NUMBER
TWO. DO YOU NEED ME TO READ
THESE? NO, I HAVE THEM HERE.
OKAY LET'S OPEN THE ROLL ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR, STARTING WITH
ITEM NUMBER TWO. AB 1943,
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WEBER MEDI-CAL,
TELEHEALTH. SENATOR NGUYEN MADE
THE MOTION. THE CURRENT VOTE IS
TEN ZERO. CHAIR. VOTING AYE.
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL. SMALLWOOD,
CUEVAS I SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS I
VOTE IS EIGHT ZERO 11 RATHER
ZERO. THE CONSENT CALENDAR IS
OUT. NEXT ITEM IS ITEM NUMBER
THREE AB 2250. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WEBER. SOCIAL DETERMINANTS OF
HEALTH MOTION DO PASS AS AMENDED
. WE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS MOVED BY SENATOR
HURTADO. CURRENT VOTE EIGHT
ZERO. CHAIR VOTING AYE. PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLE. SENATOR NGUYEN
GROVE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS I
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. I VOTE IS
NINE ZERO. ITEM NUMBER THREE AB
2250 IS OUT. LAST ITEM. ITEM
NUMBER 12, AB 3245. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER PATTERSON. COVERAGE FOR
COLORECTAL CANCER. MOTION BY
SENATOR WIENER. CURRENT VOTE
NINE ZERO CHAIR VOTING AYE.
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL MENGIBAR.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS I SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS I COMING BACK. VOTE IS
TEN ZERO. THAT MATTER IS OUT
SEEING NO OTHER BUSINESS BEFORE
THE HEALTH COMMITTEE. THE HEALTH
COMMITTEE HEARING IS ADJOURNED.